il ya quelqu'un mon père m'a toujours
bercé d'histoire sur un monde caché
peuplé de courageux guerriers qui
veillent et nous protège mais ce
merveilleux
il m'a toujours dit le fait que tu mets
rien vu ne signifie pas qu'il a rien
qu'est ce qui t'a rhume petit fils un
escargot qui part en fait je suis une
limace jeunes et les hommes feuilles
protecteur de la forêt
verizon
je veux détruire la forêt mais je ne le
ferais qu'une fois leurs tâches et des
attentive
et avec nous maintenant
papa vient de faire un rêves délirants y
avait des limaces qui parle et de doutes
isolda et bonjour à c'est pas vrai basée
aux îles orcades richaud